hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the moon we are in a
world that doesn't exist there's so many
things to think about all at once and I
don't even know how to address it I mean
for one if I lost my brother's kid and I
had an opportunity to have him back I
don't know what I'd do to get that but
uh it's all fake
I wonder if the real NASA looks like
this probably not it's constructed in
part with Johnny's beliefs after all is
a wiki of existing facts tainted by
personal fairy tales indeed it's odd
though dear birds and see none oh sorry
Neil I really thought there was a good
chance what and this is the break room
his David he's a mission specialist nice
to meet you um Johnny at least he got
into NASA I guess you think he made it
to the end even if he did it'd take more
than just a few years to become an
astronaut sorry and find the last link
then I'd hate to miss the finale Oh
Oh No what's going on are we out of time
I don't know what's going on
ah and here's our other new recruit
River right good to have you on board
hello I'm John who Alice aw she wasn't
what the boob IVA was she deleted her
now I told you I just moved her what she
does with her life here is still up to
her this new world it's based on public
data and Johnny's own beliefs and since
rivers data as an individual is not
recorded in the public domain
it all comes from Johnny but even then
that merely increases the odds how are
you sure that didn't even work I wasn't
could have gone very badly you know you
were never one to take risks Neil just
say I won this round we still have two
spare helmets right I think Johnny
depreciate some company
I don't even know what to think anymore
I guess it's the best of both worlds but
Han well that's a song that he wrote for
River
you
he wrote in himself apparently rather
repetitive if you asked me though what's
it called to the moon I like that name
oh no what to think
oh man okay that's what I thought when
they said they had the two elements
we're gonna hook up the other dudes Oh
Oh it just messes with your mind like
the what-ifs of it all I mean that's
what every great story this is what if
and now in the adult stage prime
astronaut time Brian launching out of a
space shuttle time oh there you are you
two should go get some rest
tomorrow's a big day commander awesome
pants this new reality why can't he be
named commander awesome pants
are they gonna launch off to the moon
now they're gonna see the lighthouses in
the sky
oh where am I now why am i walking on a
bridge oh I'm gonna see the launch from
a distance I want to be an astronaut too
dad one day son
you just might mess but head left that
is my MA
not as crazy as before oh no did you
think that they would make it ha did you
know the way she is I didn't think she
would succeed I guess I was wrong
all the better than isn't it yes I'm
happy for them
you know that's my brother in that
shuttle Wow
yep I once wrote a book about this too
with a less optimistic ending I might
have to change that after all
hey dr. Watts right thank you for
letting us in here
yeah yeah he was the one who requested
it did you find out why he wanted to go
to the moon
sure and what'll happened there let's
just say it was a bunch of sappy cheese
has sorted itself out oh that's all
you're gonna summarize it as you know
there were quite a few times last night
when I thought we'd lost Johnny I think
he consciously held on to you to wait
for you too he's rather patient then I
just hope it's worth the wait
gone now your colleagues waiting Oh
I thought this might be a good view good
enough to cut off the traffic ax sure
even if they were real
well this is it all we've worked for
ready to initiate it Oh No and I yet I
need to fainting happens I'm blaming and
I need to save I haven't saved in a long
time I've been so wrapped up in what's
been going on
Oh God I guess come up here oh why why
not you're just gonna push me off the
ledge again aren't you
probably for the views with the odds
come on
oh I don't know what to feel I figure I
should be happy for them but I know it's
not real
lives aren't perfect
I suppose if it means that an old man
can die happy there lies worth it oh no
no no one's watching him
no one's monitoring the pace no no no no
because one day I'm going to befriend
one of them
I thought he was dying zoo dying
you
watch out birds
it's so cheerful why not feel so
conflicted
ah
oh man
oh god they're just gonna fast-forward
through the rest of their life Oh
I hear that heartbeat monitor I hear it
oh oh no oh he's on the moon yet oh no
wait am i doing something here
no okay
oh come on okay anyway oh god the kids
we see how it ends I know I should be
happy like it's beautiful that he got
what he wanted but how is it better I
know it's not
I thought he was gonna lose like all the
all memories of river at first and
that's why I was conflicted as to what
was going on in the beginning but oh my
god
it's just like like it's it's the idea
that it's not real and that in a weird
way when I was going backwards in time
through all the memories that I saw you
know there were bad moments in troubled
times and all that stuff and there was
times when he was like conflicted on
being with River but it was it was it
made the moments when they had you know
a good time together all that more
better it was just like I don't know
it's just the idea that it can all just
be rewritten and turned into this other
story
it seems just I don't know it just seems
fake to me and I don't know if I like it
better oh and it raises so many
questions as to what really matters and
poor guy goddamn I mean whether it was
right or not to want to go to the moon
like the two doctors trying to make it
work out and get to the point where he
could I don't know if it was worth it
all but he'll I who am I to judge assist
this is an old man that wants to have a
happy moment before he dies like why did
he even want to go to the moon in the
now like why did he want to go to the
moon when he was on his deathbed what
was the original motivation behind it
all I mean was it all just from his
childhood that it forgot because his
brother died I mean if I could have a
chance to get like if my brother would
ever die and I had a chance to see him
again then as God is no telling what I
do anyway here is thanks off you go now
I still can't believe Johnny just willed
the house to Lily like that who else was
there to give it to us
terrible place for burials though if
there's a landslide they'd be swimming
with the fishes still a little too soon
knots never soon enough nice new
ringtone hello Eva here we're on our way
new patient new patient let's roll
oh man God what kind of job
fell episode one to the moon
excuse me what just happened there wait
a minute that changes a whole lot of
things the eyes you gotta back up a step
get back up a second
you're golden Susie's gotta be why you
doing
what's going on there huh who's wait a
minute
something right no no no no no no no no
no what no good no no no hell no no
Irish - no no what's going on here I
need you guys filming out what the hell
is happening here because that look like
they were stealing them somebody's
memories whose Mavericks was Eva's is it
even memories Haven that write binary
okay so I don't know what the hell
happened there but obviously there's
gonna be more of this game and I want to
play but you guys tell me in the
description below is there multiple
endings to this game are the things that
I missed are the things that I could
have seen differently like what are your
thoughts on the whole conundrum of if
you could change your life would you and
in the end would it even matter I don't
know I've thought about that before out
on all honesty I wouldn't change my life
for a gosh darn second cuz it led me to
where I am today you know I've had a lot
of hardships and troubles in my life but
you know I don't let them count against
Who I am because I wouldn't change it
because of where I ended up you know no
I'm able to do these videos and yo
entertain you guys and I'm able to do
these cool things in my life and you
know I I would count myself lucky that I
haven't been through worse so and then I
came out of what I did you know just
fine
I imagine that a lot of you people out
there might be struggling with certain
situations because you're experiencing
them right now as opposed to then being
past events if you've already moved on
from but you know just know that
don't try to try to think that going
back and changing something would make
your life better is never it's never
even not option that is kind of why this
rubbed me the wrong way is because this
whole game was based on the whole idea
of going back and changing your life is
based on an idea that you know it would
change who you are today but it's it's
all fake you know it can't be done you
can't go back no matter how hard you
wish it to be true and like if you're
struggling through a situation right now
I just want you to know that
as bad as it can be and I Paul can't
even imagine how bad it can be for some
of you but thus know that you have
choices right now especially if you're
going through right now to make it
something that changes you for the worse
are the better so just remember that
it's gonna affect who you will be you
can ever affect who you were what you
decided in the past but you can affect
you can decide right now to affect who
you're gonna be in the future so that's
what really matters
I just cherish what you got coz that's
important you know you could lose it at
any moment and I wish you know I wish I
could have done more things in the past
but I wouldn't change it cuz I am Who I
am my name is markiplier and I'm glad to
have played this game for you and I'm
glad that you guys join me for this
journey it was a wild one like I played
this all of this in two sessions
literally one time and then another one
I had more time and I couldn't put it
down so it's like a great book you know
you can't just put it down
so either way thank you all so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this game I
hope you enjoyed the story I sure did it
was phenomenal from front to start
everyone was saying this like a
fantastic game one of the great stories
in the game I would kind of agree just
for the sake that it asks so many really
deep questions and that's important so
enough of my yammering I'm gonna cut out
here so thank you guys again for
watching if you want to see more let's
place that I've done there's so many
more in the past down in the description
below or will be included in the
annotations over there
since thanks again everybody for
watching and just remember to think
deeply on you know what's really
important in life so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye just like I'm supposed to just
like daddy Tommy daddy he never thought
that I could be a doctor he never
thought I could be a doctor doctor don't
you think you should focus on the page
shut up nurse yeah yeah yeah I'm okay
all right okay